[Musique]
bon le sol a tout de suite patron je ne
sois pas si pressée nounours et jamie
mac en jeu qu'ils vont être contents
popopopops gros bobos soir les enfants
vous aussi vous allez être contents car
nounours vous a réservé une surprise
au soir les petits
gars là a porté la super leicester de
filippi oui je vais vous la raconter
alors je me pose
où en étions-nous
[Musique]
l'année matin le lendemain matin
philippines se réveilla de très bonnes
mains elle prit son tambour et
moi aussi je vais jouer du tambour le
matin en me réveillant au oui ça frappe
ici la tap m les parents de philippine
ravi d'être réveillé citons demandeurs à
leur petite fille ronde est gentil ce
qu'elle désirait de si bonne heure
répondit philippines sa maman avait déjà
chauffée du lin du chocolat est posé sur
la table un paul des assiettes du sucre
du miel du fromage un appétit de la
confiture de prunes de la confiture de
pages de la confiture d'orange d'abricot
de la confiture de confiture mur elle
avait déposé un pot de confiture de
phrase
lorsque
piti piti piti
le lapin blanc entre a et mangera toute
la confiture de fraises
à tend la main à temps et philippine qui
avait très envie de jouer avec lui
essayé de l'attraper mais le lapin blanc
se sauva bien vite et philippine se mit
à pleurer
pour se consoler de ne pas avoir joué
avec le lapin blanc
philippines fit un excellent petit
déjeuner puis
repris son tambour
[Musique]
sketch bien
écouter la suite il fait beau allons
nous promener dans les proies propos ça
qui m'a poussé
je ne me rappelle plus je l'y aide
apportée lassus c'est malin
je vous le promets je vous la porterez
la prochaine fois je vous laisse le lit
oui vous êtes content
ça nous fait d'amis allons les enfants
où
annie neige notamment les nuits les plus
la jette à la ligne homme
fait deux tours
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle était très jolie ton histoire
nounours niko lol patronales l'ont
beaucoup plus on n'y va pas trop en
route la nuit les enfants fait de pur
[Musique]
oh
e